Recently, I’ve been mostly indulging my casual EDH
instincts in my videos, as I think there are lots
of often-neglected things to look for in a deck
aside from its ability to win. Unfortunately,
those things are gonna have to go on the
backburner for this video, because I’m
going to be talking about how I built my sweatiest
deck, a deck whose construction process focused on
making it as powerful as possible on the budget
I gave it. My hope is that this video can serve
as a bit of a guide on how to build something
powerful without breaking the bank, a useful
thing to be able to do in a game where different
players have different monetary resources to build
decks with. With that said, my construction of
this deck began in the place where a lot of decks
start—figuring out an intriguing commander
to look into. In this case, I opted for the
partner commander pairing of Malcolm, Keen Eyed
Navigator and Francisco, Fowl Marauder, a pair I
picked out because I enjoy Dimir and I also enjoy
pirates. Malcolm is going to be doing the heaviest
lifting of these two, generating treasures
whenever I hit opponents, but Francisco is no
slouch either—offering great filtering and rapidly
building up in power and toughness for purposes of
smacking my opponents. And ultimately, the sheer
versatility that this pairing offers is what makes
them so potent. My mindset going into building the
deck was this: if I make Francisco and Malcolm my
default turn 2 and 3 plays and then land a 1 drop
pirate as often as possible, this will leave me
with a powerful filtering and treasure generating
engine fully online by turn 3. So that’s the
resource-generating core of my deck—Francisco,
Malcolm, and ten one-cost pirates. Some of these
are a bit janky, but they perform the function of
being a 1-mana pirate, which is all I care about.
Once I had my commanders and the first ten
cards of the deck out of the way, I began to do
research. I was looking to build a new high-power
deck and I knew that my starting point was pretty
strong, so I began looking around for good ways to
end the game, figuring that I’d need something a
bit more focused that just hitting people with
whatever pirates I have laying around. Front
and center on the EDHRec page for Francisco and
Malcolm were Thassa’s Oracle based combos, one of
the strongest combos in EDH, but this combo would
have eaten a lot of my budget and I frankly just
find it pretty bland. I looked around a bit more
before being reminded of a card I’d had in the
back of my mind for several years—Time Sieve—and
that card seemed decidedly more my speed. See,
Malcolm hopefully creates 3 treasures per turn,
and Time Sieve spends 5 artifacts to grant an
extra turn. Something you may notice is that
these two numbers, 3 and 5, aren’t very far
apart—with two additional artifacts per turn, we
can just keep on taking turns indefinitely. With
this revelation, I went looking for things to help
me bridge this gap. A card that immediately jumped
to mind was Academy Manufactor, and this ended
up being accompanied by Storm Fleet Negotiator,
an evasive pirate that typically produces 2-3 map
tokens per attack. The third dedicated option I
have for this is Worldwalker Helm, a card printed
in The Big Score that operates very similarly to
Manufactor, and this ended up replacing Ruthless
Knave as my third supporting piece. There are also
a few other cards that produce one artifact
per turn as well as some cards that are or
that produce a single artifact, and I call these
play extenders—cards that serve to buy the deck
time when it’s beginning to take extra turns but
doesn’t yet have a way to guarantee these turns
being indefinite. After adding all these cards to
boost Time Sieve up to being a full combo plan,
I decided to add some tutors to find my combo. The
fact that Worldwalker Helm and Academy Manufactor
are artifacts is great, as it means that artifact
tutors can find everything we need to win. So
naturally, we start here with Fabricate, Reshape,
and Whir of Invention, all artifact tutors that
effectively cost 3 or less mana for purposes
of finding Time Sieve. These are accompanied
by Lim-Dul’s Vault and Ringsight, both somewhat
more generic tutors that can find a wide range of
cards, though Vault can require a hefty shave
off my life total if I’m going for a specific
card such as Time Sieve. These five tutors are
supplemented with three transmute cards, which are
great for their flexibility as they can either be
cast normally as control spells or be transmuted
to tutor for a card of their mana cost, with 2
and 3 being the key mana values in this deck.
So with that, I had the deck’s engine, and I had
the deck’s wincon. But what ended up rounding out
the other 44 nonland cards in the deck? To get to
that, I need to talk about perhaps the strangest
thing about this deck—its extreme consistency. I
can basically present what this deck is trying to
do as a five-turn map. Turns 1-3 in a conventional
game consist of a one cost pirate turn 1,
Francisco turn 2, and Malcolm turn 3. Turn
4 is the setup turn, where I play any other
cards that might assist in my combo. Turn 5 is
the combo turn—this is usually the turn where
I’ll tutor for Time Sieve if needed, play it,
and then hopefully begin a series of however
many turns are needed to beat down my opponents.
Sometimes turns 1-3 go a bit differently, usually
if I don’t have access to a one drop or if I have
something different I want to play turn 2 or 3,
but needing to play Francisco or Malcolm turn 4 is
decidedly not the end of the world—the fact that I
have that turn where nothing needs to be played
gives me a bit of wiggle room in my curve out.
The deck also varies a little in when it goes
off—I’ll sometimes delay the combo to turn 6,
especially if I needed to spend my treasures
interacting with my opponents in some way on an
earlier turn. Likewise, the deck is able to combo
off on turn 4 about 10% of the time when things
line up just right, though this also usually means
going for the win without counterspell backup,
so I’ll only do this if my opponents are
tapped out or if I expect one of them to
do something big on their next turn. The speed
of this deck is limited by the fact that Malcolm
generates at most three treasures per turn,
meaning that it generally takes multiple
turns with Malcolm on board to generate
the treasure surpluses needed to go off.
To talk about what I chose for the rest of
the cards in the deck, I need to go back to
that critical setup turn—turn 4. This turn is
where I develop all manner of things that might
be useful for purposes of comboing off. The first
of these is draw—Francisco’s filtering is lovely,
but I’ve found that if I don’t already have what
I need to combo in hand, I’m generally using that
filtering to aggressively dig for tutors and
combo pieces, passing up potentially useful
cards. For that reason, having a bit of draw
in addition is good, and there’s one particular
type of draw that stands out above all others
in this deck—cards that let me draw when I hit
people. This deck runs all four Bident of Thassa
effects that exist, and this is for good reason.
Landing one of these on turn 4 is great—that
extra stream of cards almost always smooths out
any issues I might have in comboing off, and these
effects can even generate enough value to let me
keep up as a midrange deck in the event my Time
Sieve bites the dust. Other draw effects include
Combat Research, Curious Inquiry, and Curious
Obsession—the draw post combat-damage is nice,
and +1/+1 is also nice for I’m going into a
turn 3 with a 0/1 Francisco and want to play
that plus a two-drop rather than Malcolm. The
rest of my draw suite has been rotating around
a bit between different options—currently I’m
running Treasure Cruise and Dig Through Time,
delve cards that can utilize the unnecessary
stuff that Francisco has dumped into my graveyard.
Another type of card I tend to develop on
my setup turn is mana rocks—since all of
these tap for mana immediately the two mana
ones effectively cost a single colorless,
and weaving them into a turn 4 can offer a nice
burst of mana for my early combo turns and also
an artifact to be sacrificed to Time Sieve if
needed. The last main type of card I find myself
playing on my setup turn is additional pirates.
Theoretically a one-drop pirate, a Francisco,
and a Malcolm maxes out my commander triggers per
turn, but realistically creatures die sometimes,
and there are also games where I have one-drop on
the ground and need a flier for an opponent with
blockers, or alternatively an unblockable creature
to get past fliers. Some of my pirates have that
extra little bit of evasion, and others have other
upsides such as having some sweet removal stapled
to them or offering a bit of extra filtering. A
final supportive pirate is Oaken Siren, a bulk
common that feels like it was designed just for
this deck—it flies, it can tap post-combat to cast
my combo pieces, and it itself is an artifact that
can be sacrificed to Time Sieve. Beautiful card,
love it. Since this deck is still a pirates deck
in addition to being a combo deck, I also ended
up adding an alternative wincon—Haunted One. This
card pumps my team’s power by 4 if both commanders
swing, which can turn a handful of evasive
pirates into a veritable player-killing machine.
At this point, I need to get to arguably
the thing that gives the deck most of its
power—the interaction suite. My deck is running
13 counterspells, a number that may strike a lot
of casual EDH players as mildly obscene, but this
number works out well for a couple reasons. First
of all, the deck’s core is very compact, being
comprised of the command zone and 19 cards from
the deck. Even having added in a bunch of utility
stuff to help smooth things out, there’s still a
lot of space to work with, and counterspells are a
great way to fill that space because they can both
protect what I’m doing and hinder what opponents
are doing. The other reason counterspells work so
well is because of treasures. I’ve talked before
about the issue of counterspells effectively
wasting mana if they aren’t used, and a great
thing about treasures is that they’re never
wasted mana due to their one-time-use nature. The
fact that they serve this dual purpose of being
both stored mana and also artifact tokens for Time
Sieve is quite good—I can tap out every turn and
still have mana available for counterspells if
they’re needed. Now, spending treasures to play
counterspells is still consuming a resource, so a
lot of times I do leave up a land or two to reduce
the number of treasures I need to sacrifice, but
even when I do need to spend treasures it’s still
usually fine. The deck can often sacrifice a
couple treasures and still combo off on time,
and even when it does need to spend enough
treasures to delay its combo by a turn, that’s
still not too bad for me as it forces my opponents
to spend mana and lets me avoid needing to cough
up the mana to recast Malcolm. I’m also running
some number of removal spells, though this count
can afford to be lower since I have counterspells
to counter spooky things before they hit the
board, and the deck also aims to win before most
decks get around to playing a lot of big bombs.
Lastly, I’ll just talk briefly about the
manabase. This deck’s manabase follows a
simple principle—I want untapped, colored mana
as often as possible. Following from this goal,
every single land in the deck can theoretically
play a pirate turn 1, and though this means
running some spicy lands such as Gemstone
Mine that can see diminishing returns later,
these are worth it for purposes of guaranteeing
that I’m able to set up my engine properly. This
desire for untapped colored mana also motivates
the deck’s land count, currently sitting at 35.
My curve is extremely low and Francisco actively
encourages me to run fewer lands—I want him to
hit a nonland card on his first explore trigger so
that he can attack the following turn, and he also
offers a way to dig for additional land plays
in games where I keep a two land hand. And if
I had access to expensive dual lands that could
guarantee having the colors I need, I probably
would cut at least two lands. But since I don’t
have access to these, I’ve opted to stick with
the current land count, though I may experiment
with cutting down to 34 lands at some point.
Alright, so I’ve been hyping this deck up a lot,
and it is quite good. However, there are some
notable weaknesses with the deck, and I think it’s
useful to talk about these and think about how to
solve them. The first is that it usually won’t
have mana to deal with removal before the end of
combat on turn 3. Malcolm generates treasures when
pirates connect with opponents, but if an opponent
has an instant speed kill spell for Malcolm before
I get treasures, the deck has no response unless
it has a Foil or a Misdirection in hand, and it
will likely need to delay its combo attempt by one
or more turns. This issue I’m currently choosing
to take the L on, as it has only come up a couple
times and the free counterspells I’m not currently
running aren’t all that appealing to me. Another
weakness that I alluded to earlier is that this
deck’s engine relies on dealing combat damage to
opponents, so if there are one or more opponents
that it’s unable to attack, it won’t perform at
full efficiency. This issue is decidedly more
manageable—the deck’s commanders already have
flying, and most of the pirates in the deck have
either flying or a more robust form of evasion.
The deck can also usually afford to only hit two
opponents for a turn or two, and Francisco gets
big pretty fast, so a lot of times the best bet is
to send him at the opponent with fliers and force
chump blocks in order to open up that opponent
for further attacks. I’ve also considered cards
such as Thieves’ Tools to help with this, though
I haven’t felt the need to add that just yet.
The third weakness of the deck is the most
problematic and also the most complicated,
and that’s that the deck has a difficult
time recovering from major setbacks. The
main reason for this is that the deck’s
card quality just isn’t that high,
and in my opinion this is the biggest
factor that holds this deck back from
competing with competitive EDH decks. cEDH
decks typically have very high card quality,
with most nonland cards being extremely
efficient and/or flexible. Even in Yuriko,
the cEDH deck that’s most similar to this
one, there are powerful supporting cards
with impactful effects that require no setup
and no other cards to utilize. By contrast,
this deck has a lean mana curve and much of its
space is dominated by cards that don’t do much
without its commanders in play. Even the bigger
draw spells require creatures in play to be good,
and though the deck has plenty of counterspells
to keep away board wipes during the most pivotal
turns, I’ve had games where things stalled out
and the deck’s board eventually got worn down
through attrition. This is the weakness that
I’ve been trying hardest to solve, and I’ve had
a few ideas. A funky card I’m trying out at the
moment is Echo Storm, which functions as a play
extender if I’m trying to combo, and it also can
be a big burst of value off a single card if I’m
trying to recover from a point of my commanders
getting killed multiple times. I may also opt to
trade out a couple removal spells for additional
draw, which would help in general with stall-outs
and hopefully prevent me from fully losing my
board. Solving a budget-related problem without
increasing the budget of the deck is difficult,
but it’s a fun challenge to grapple with.
Even with its weaknesses, this deck does a good
job demonstrating what high-power commander on
a budget can look like, or to some extent,
what it needs to look like. You can build a
lot of different decks up to a relatively high
power level, but as you creep into the higher
end of high-power-casual and begin to approach
the wild world of cEDH, decks need to be very
streamlined in both what they do and how well
they can stop other people from doing things,
and this becomes doubly true when you add in
a budget element that restricts card quality.
Ultimately, building a deck of this caliber
on a limited budget relies on having two
interconnected attributes—an efficient gameplan,
typically helped out by a powerful command zone,
and also a high interaction density. I like to
say that the best way to build a strong deck is
to take a fundamentally broken magic card and
put it into your command zone, and while this
statement isn’t untrue, a more helpful phrasing
might be that it’s helpful to have your command
zone contribute to both resource generation
and to defeating your opponents. In this case,
my command zone is part of an infinite turns
combo, and it also offers some ramp and filtering.
We can see this pattern echoed in other powerful
budget commanders such as Niv Mizzet, Yuriko, and
Ellivere of the Wild Court. The fact that these
sorts of commanders support a deck’s gameplan so
holistically is important, because it allows that
plan to be relatively compact for how powerful it
is, not occupying too much deck space. When
you’re evaluating powerful commander decks,
what the deck is doing proactively to win and
what the deck is doing reactively to deal with
opposing plays often exist in a state of tension
due to deck space being limited. So naturally,
if you’re able to improve the efficiency of the
deck’s proactive gameplan and let it keep up the
same power level with fewer slots, this will
give the deck more space to be faster, more
interactive, or a little of both. That interaction
density is the other part of what makes powerful
commander decks so powerful—I know a lot of
casual EDH players who dislike counterspells,
but the fact that counterspells can both hinder
opponents and protect your own gameplan from hate
is very useful, and the usefulness of both
them and removal actually scales with deck
speed. One of the reasons people don’t run very
much interaction in casual commander is because
the format is full of durdly midrange decks that
are going to be playing out a long stream of nasty
high-cost spells in the late game, and dealing
with one player’s cards often just allows a
different player to play their stuff unimpeded.
But when your opponents only have a handful of
turns to develop their concerning things before
you’re threatening a win, the number of things
that actually require dealing with will often
be smaller and easier to dismantle. Countering
one of a player’s three bombs isn’t all that
great, but countering a single combo piece or
value engine can sometimes be enough to slow an
opponent down for long enough to execute a win.
To cap off this video, I would like to
reiterate—decks being strong isn’t everything,
and a lot of players are decidedly not looking
for cutthroat games with tables full of fast
combo decks. I can’t really play with this deck
in my normal playgroup without it feeling wildly
out of place, which is kind of a downside
for a deck to have. I’d also argue that the
current EDH space puts too much emphasis on
ways to improve the raw power level of decks,
without considering how playing with or against
these decks ends up feeling. At the same time,
it’s a fact of life that a lot of people are
looking to make their decks more powerful, this
is a competitive card game after all. It’s also a
fact of life that different people have different
amounts of money they want to spend on the game,
and that fact can be felt in the power of decks
sometimes. Proxies are one solution to this issue,
but they will never be the whole solution, if for
no other reason than that they’re not allowed at
any Wizards of the Coast-affiliated event. Just as
it’s useful to know when to hold off on cramming
powerful cards into a deck, it’s also useful to
know exactly how to ratchet up the power of a
deck when you do want that, and being able to
do so without needing to crank up the card quality
with expensive staples is a great skill to have.
Thanks for making it to the end, this
video ended up a bit longer than I was
intending. I’m going to be doing another
deck review this month over on my Patreon,
so if you want a chance at getting your
deck reviewed by me, you can head on over
there and start giving me money sometime in
the next five days. If you give me enough
money you can even join the people you
see on screen here. Pretty tempting, huh.